what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and lately we've been
talking a lot about the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and today is
no exception we're going to be going
over everything that has been rumored
for phase six and Marvel's phase seven
the phase that will kick off an entirely
New Saga for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe after Secret Wars we'll be
going over what we can expect and
everything that's been rumored and
confirmed so far now we're going to be
going over a lot of projects today for
phase six and phase seven as I mentioned
some of these are rumored some of these
are confirmed some have been reported on
by some Outlets but haven't been
officially confirmed by Marvel Studios
yet but basically the list we're going
over today is a huge list of everything
that's been posted online and compiled
together and put on the internet so
don't expect all of it to actually
happen some of it will happen but don't
expect everything because of course it
is the internet and we've even had some
rumors going around lately from some
I'll do air quotes here source sources
stating that Marvel Studios is
intentionally putting out fake
information to throw these insiders and
leakers off which totally makes sense
because if you're trying to keep things
secretive what are you going to do well
you're going to throw some
misinformation out there but like I said
I'm assuming at least half of this is
true and of course it's always fun to
kind of just go over this and think
about what could happen and right now I
feel that if you were one of those
people who weren't So Satisfied with
phase four I feel like phase five six
and seven are going to be better which
of course is always exciting so let's go
ahead and dive into all of these listed
projects coming in phase six and phase
seven we'll start off of course with
phase six phase six is going to start
off with Wonder Man which is going to be
a series this is confirmed at this point
right now it is assumed that it will
come during fall of 2024 then in October
2024 Marvel Zombies which is going to be
an animated series here's where it gets
cool in October of 2024 as well we could
be getting a Ghost Rider special this is
going to be done like werewolf by night
apparently right now a Nova special is
in play at Marvel Studios as well it
really looks like Marvel Studios might
be taking the route of specials to
introduce new characters to the MCU
which I'm not against werewolf by Knight
worked very very well and fingers
crossed we do get a Ghost Rider special
on October 2024. also in Fall of 2024
Spider-Man freshman year which is going
to be an animated series should be
coming however recently it seems like
it's going through some trouble and
might get delayed so hang tight on that
then of course in November of 2024
Deadpool 3 this of course is confirmed
already and everybody is super super
excited another one that seems really
likely that has been going around lately
in Fall of 2024 we could be getting a
Vision Quest Series this of course will
follow the events of spectral Vision who
we saw in one division at the very end
who kind of just took off and we haven't
heard anything about him since but he's
still out there and of course Marvel
Studios is going to have to address that
at some point now in Winter of 2024
there's a rumored midnight Angels series
now they just introduced the midnight
angels in Black Panther wakanda forever
and Ryan coogler has signed on for
multiple wakanda spin-off projects this
could be one of them so this seems
likely but still not officially
confirmed then in December of 2024 we
could be getting Spider-Man 4. this
could be inaccurate because according to
the cosmiccircus.com the date for
Spider-Man 4 right now should be July
12th of 2024 before this date so this
one is most likely wrong but in January
of 2025 we could be getting the Nova
special we know that's coming we just
don't know when yet hopefully in January
then following Nova in February 2025 the
Fantastic Four we know this is confirmed
then in Spring 2025 there could be a
midnight Suns Series this would be kind
of the darker more Supernatural side of
the MCU and their team which I'm sure
everybody would love to see another
project rumored for spring 2025 is Moon
night season 2 at this point in time it
does seem like a season two is pretty
much all but confirmed I'm sure they
will officially let us know about Moon
Knight season 2 very soon then of course
in May 2025 we have Avengers the King
Dynasty of course this is confirmed in
summer 2025 X-Men 97 the animated series
season 2. and yes a season 2 has already
been confirmed also shung Chi 2 has been
confirmed already and this is listed for
July 2025 so far this makes sense
because we know xiangchi is going to be
a part of Secret Wars and we know he's
going to have another film before that
takes place it then says we could be
getting the Young Avengers which could
be a series in summer of 2025 we know
the Young Avengers are coming we just
don't know when yet hopefully summer of
2025 then in Fall 2025 the Animated
Series Spider-Man sophomore year this
would obvi obviously be a season 2 to
Spider-Man freshman year but he would be
a sophomore now then it has listed for
October 2025 a Mephisto special now
rumor has it that Mephisto is going to
be coming in the Iron Heart series and
that he is going to be played by Sasha
Baron Cohen this is pretty much
confirmed but Marvel Studios has not yet
officially said anything but it looks
like it is going to happen then in
November of 2025 we have armor Wars
which is now going to be a movie not a
show winter 2025 a nomad series December
2025 an Abomination special we just saw
abomination in She-Hulk so it could be
very possible that he goes on to get his
own special now this one is interesting
it says in January of 2026 we could be
getting a special called the Conqueror
this would obviously be about Kang and
maybe it would even be about Nathaniel
Richards who goes on to become king the
Conqueror when he first discovers time
travel it's unclear on whether or not
we're going to see any of that in
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania or in
the Kang Dynasty so maybe after the Kang
Dynasty but before Secret Wars Marvel
gives us a special about King to show us
who he really is I think that would be
really really cool then in summer of
2026 it says we could be getting an
Illuminati series I personally think
it's only a matter of time until we get
an Illuminati team in our main universe
so it just makes sense then in February
2026
eternals 2 we know and eternals 2 has
been confirmed already by Marvel Studios
we just don't know when although it does
make sense that this would happen before
Secret Wars because we assume the
eternals will be fighting in the fight
it then says in Spring 2026 two
different series one Miss Marvel season
2 and 2 World War Hulk a series now I'm
not so sure about World War Hulk being a
series I think it's going to be a film
and even in She-Hulk Jennifer Walters
mentioned a Hulk movie so I'm gonna go
ahead and say it's going to be a movie
not a series but then of course in May
2026 to end phase six and the Multiverse
Saga Avengers Secret Wars if even half
of this is true which we basically know
that half of it is true this is a pretty
dang good phase six there's a lot in
here to really look forward to that is
really really exciting but let's go
ahead and jump right into phase seven as
well and I should note that moving
forward into phase seven these are a
little bit more unknown so take these
with a grain of salt but starting it off
with what we'll call a rumored list is a
Power Pack series now many people might
not actually know about the power pack
it's a group of family members
consisting of Alex Julie Jack and Katie
power I remember that this was actually
rumored to be in development or at least
a possibility for Marvel Studios like
three four years ago and I think it
would be a really cool project to see so
hopefully this does eventually come in
Phase seven I don't think it fits
anywhere in Phase 5 or phase six so
hopefully in the next Saga then another
rumored one is a secret Warrior series
reason this one was also rumored about
three years ago as well secret Warriors
would be cool but I also wonder if
they're kind of putting this with a
secret Invasion however Quake is a part
of the secret Warriors and it's been
rumored recently that she could be
coming back so fingers crossed now this
one actually has a date of July 2026 and
it is a Namor project which apparently
is pretty confirmed and yeah that makes
sense because Namor as a villain was
incredible and we know in the comics
he's a major character in the Marvel
Universe and is even a part of the
Illuminati so I'm assuming he'll have a
big role in the MCU as well then we have
a rumored She-Hulk season 2 that just
makes sense November of 2026 it's
interesting that this has an exact date
the X-Men an X-Men film I would take
this with a grain of salt we do know a
movie for them is coming we know it's
coming after Secret Wars so phase seven
but as far as that actual release date
goes take that with a grain of salt the
next two we have listed are agents of
Atlas a series and a photon series both
of these seem pretty likely agents of
Atlas was reported on a very long time
ago and Photon well we got Photon in
Wanda vision and she is also coming in
the Marvel so it would make sense that
she would go on to have her own series
as well now the next one is Black
Panther 3. now Ryan coogler has recently
mentioned that he does have ideas for a
third black panther film and no spoilers
but if you have seen the movie you know
that it does look like they have plans
for not only one other movie but perhaps
a few more it then says in Spring of
2027 we will get a black knight series
that is currently already in development
now if you've seen the eternals if
you've seen the post-credits scene you
know that this is coming and I'm
actually really really excited for this
one it's a shame we have to wait so long
then of course we have listed Doctor
Strange three we knew that was coming
from the post-credits scene of Doctor
Strange 2. it then says there is a
squadron Supreme series possibly in
development right now now this was
reported on this week I believe I
actually think it was reported on only a
couple of days ago so this is most
likely coming in Phase seven but there
is a tiny chance it could possibly come
in phase six but I doubt it I'm assuming
phase seven then of course a 10 Ring
series that was teased after the first
Shang Chi film we know this is coming
and then this lists a date for October
2027 a Doctor Doom special now I hate
this but this actually does kind of make
sense I hate it because it's so far away
but I don't think Dr Doom is going to be
a big figure relatively soon I do think
they're going to save him as the big bad
for the next Saga so having a special
introduce him in 2027 might be what
we're in for and then the last two films
that it has listed for phase 7 are an
X-Men 2 movie and a fantastic four two
movie as well which of course we know
that we're going to get so this list of
movies and shows and specials is pretty
insane if even half of these are true we
are in for a really really big treat
with with Marvel Studios and the MCU
over the next handful of years it's
going to be very very exciting but hey
let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comments down below do you
like this list would you change anything
let me know all of your thoughts don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof